yo what is up everybody this is prestige
your man luigi here with another
Borland's the pre-sequel video today
we're gonna be looking at the shock drop
slaughter
it's pre-order bonus which is the doll
training facility abandoned doll
training facility if you pre-ordered
Borland's pre-sequel put a little bit of
money to towards it before the release
date you have access to this and I'm
gonna be showing you the location to
this and kind of what it's about it's
kind of like a it's kind of like think
slaughterhouse from Bor lines to its
it's really similar to that kind of a
whole five round they kill people yeah
so hope you enjoy the video alright so
the first thing you're gonna want to do
is head to Outlands canyon this is I've
beaten the game by this point so I had a
kind of everything unlock so you're
gonna need outlines Canyon unlocked see
on the map it's gonna be at the far edge
of the map the doll banded doll training
facility you're just gonna have to run
all the way across the map it's right
next to the basketball court where there
was some of the basketball side mister
side missions if you've done any side
missions in Outlands canyon that'll give
you a little guide to where it is or you
can just kind of follow where I go I
just go around kind of the southern most
part of the map that you can they go
lead you to the area and then I just
dodge most of the bad guys if you want
to fight them I kind of just run past
them since I'm just trying to get to the
slaughter pit the training facility I'm
kind of interchangeably calling it so
this is a this slaughter pit is just
like the one in Borderlands 2 in that
you have five rounds of progressively
harder enemies and they're kind of just
general mobs and your point is to kill
is to survive each round and kill them
however I found this one a lot easier
than the one borderline stood maybe
that's because I'm only remembering the
ultimate vault hunter a version of
Borderlands 2 one which is more powerful
but it's not too bad and you can see
here that I found at the abandoned
training facility its new location I do
not think you can fast travel to it if
you anytime you want to get here you're
gonna have to run all the way here and
so you get here and there's gonna be a
little malfunctioning board and you can
pick up your missions from it and you're
gonna get a talking head he's gonna talk
for a while but eventually when he stops
talking he sends you down into the
training area to kill a bunch of guys
and once you finish the fifth round you
go turn it in you get a unique blue
shield called the haymaker I think it's
pretty good shield having use it too
much and yeah that's basically it I'm
not gonna show you much of the gameplay
because I want you guys to have that for
yourselves to do since this is kind of
the whole experience of this so I hope
you enjoyed the video I'm appreciate you
gotta thus far and make sure you check
out my other Borderlands the pre-sequel
videos and keep looking at my channel
for more thanks for watching